*Receptionist* Expecting you dear. I'm Lilly.
*Mark* Hi Lilly.
You know you... You jiggle a lot
Which... is something I appreciate.
Hello?
Howdy hooty?
Take bad item, get popularity?
I mean... alright, I'll do it.
*Cheering*
New item: Good leg, bad leg, no leg. You're still gonna die.
Are you... you lost- I lost one leg?!
That's not an item, you just cut off my leg!
*Markimoo sounds* Eh eh ah eh eh eeh!
Ow!
I can't sprint- oh, fuck you dude!
Say "I'm a dick" for activation! *Laughing*
I'm a dick!
I'm a dick, baby!
I'm a big ol' dick!
Please, can I have my leg back?
Why did you vote for heels?
Why did you guys give me heels?
While sprinting you sometimes trip and lose all your-
I CAN'T.  SPRINT.
I have ONE LEG!
Well, I am fucked. I'm fucky, fucky, fucked.
Hey! *Creepiplier*
I've got bloody, grimy hands and only one leg!
Oh, it's a door. Goddamn it. Oh.
*Rustic music*
This isn't gonna go well. Ah, shit- oh god!
Holy shit!
If I die then at least it would be merciful on me.
Because I don't have a fucking foot!